what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are covering the single greatest Kang
story of all time uh the one that
recently completed which is basically
retold the origin of Kang which is
called only myself left to conquer the
reason why I say it's a retelling or a
reworking of his origin is because
King's origin does exist in Marvel
Comics the problem is it's scattered all
over the damn place so you've got Marvel
two-in-one Comics you've got some Marvel
Premiere Comics you've got some Journey
in a mystery you've got Fantastic Four
some Avengers stuff right you have all
kinds of comics that all just sort of
feed into this great big huge origin of
King what this does is it consolidates
all the stuff that Marvel wants to keep
it changes the things they don't and
tells us how Kane the Conqueror became
Kane to conquer here's the problem this
story relies on you understanding
ramatut and immortus and iron lad and
all that stuff so
um we have to explain that before we get
into this now we do have a full-on
explanation about Kang but even then
people said it was still a bit confusing
so we're going to replace King with you
and you are going to imagine you arcade
and we're gonna explain it that way and
if this can't solve it I don't know what
can't so here's the thing imagine you
right now living your life watching this
video and imagine that you suddenly
discovered the ability to travel back in
time right and you could do anything you
want to well I mean you're you're like
hey I'm gonna go back in time and
Conquer everything that's what I'm gonna
do I'm going to go back to the days of
ancient Egypt I'm gonna change my name
and I'm going to conquer all of
existence so you go all the way back to
the days of ancient Egypt and you start
calling yourself ramata and because of
your technological advancement you're
literally taking technology as it exists
right now back then let me tell you
something you show up there with an ink
pen you're gonna blow the minds of the
people in ancient Egypt right they're
they're gonna free they're gonna think
you're God right like they're they're
not going to know how to process that
information let alone if you took back
something like a computer which you
couldn't use or a notepad or something
along those lines right just technology
that they hadn't even considered yet so
you go back in time you change your name
to Rama Tut you rule that for for a
particular period of time now somebody
here in the present day doesn't matter
who it is realizes what you're doing
they go back in time and they basically
chase you out of ancient Egypt right
they're like you don't need to be here
uh you're a bad guy in the confines of
the comics it's the Fantastic Four let's
say whoever this person is they
basically fight you they overpower you
and you're forced to flee otherwise
you're going to die so your intention is
to say okay fine look I had the ability
to time travel I can go anywhere I want
to I mean I'm not just gonna quit after
being beat once right it's like the
dating game right try try again and so
you're like okay I'm gonna go back to
2022 and I'm gonna concoct a new plan on
how to conquer the past but along along
the way back along your journey back
here suddenly you end up in limbo and
you're just like okay what is this place
right and you explore the whole area you
start looking around you come across
technology different things like that
now while you're here in limbo it allows
you to look at the entire time stream
past present future the distant future
so you can literally watch your life
unfold from the realm of limbo and what
you do is you come to this realization
you're inevitably going to become a
villain that's a problem not only are
you going to become a villain now
there's an infinite number of universes
out there where you took different paths
and did different things and caused
different problems and maybe you form a
whole Council of yourself right like
literally hundreds of you who all meet
together occasionally and do some crazy
stuff and so what this does is it leads
to to you as you exist in limbo saying
okay I don't want to become my villain
itself I don't want to become that
villain version of me so I'm gonna stay
here and I'm gonna do everything I can
to work against myself here's the
problem what you have here is a
situation where you will inevitably have
to end up going back and becoming that
villainous version of yourself because
you exist right it's a paradox that
villainous version of yourself went back
into the past and became Rama Tut which
led you on your journey to where you are
right now calling yourself immortus
which means you know that's inevitably
going to happen no matter what you do
that's the future that's guaranteed for
you so what you're doing is trying to
work to keep that from happening now
let's move away from that version of
yourself right you're just kind of out
there doing your thing now let's say
that this future version of yourself in
the 31st Century as you're there you
come to this realization people are
going to work against me and it's
entirely possible that even even me even
even I myself may not become this
version of myself that's entirely
possible I may not I may lose the
ability to time travel or may never gain
the ability to time travel maybe I
decide to go to Burger King instead of
McDonald's and that shifts up everything
right so now I don't have the ability to
time travel any number of things could
happen that could that could prevent
that so what I need to do is I need to
go into the past and I need to meet with
my younger self and I need to make sure
that my younger self does all the things
that they're supposed to do so that I
can exist and so you do that you go back
and you meet with your younger self and
you basically tell your younger self
look I'm the guy you're going to become
and so here's what you got to do right
you gotta you gotta do this thing you
gotta do all these different things over
the course of time and if you don't
you're never going to become me well
your younger self looks at you and says
well I don't want to be you but I have
no desire to become you right you're a
dick like I don't want to be you at all
so I'm going to do everything I possibly
can not to become you and so as a result
you've made an enemy out of your younger
self now for our explanation here with
Kane the Conqueror when you went back in
time and became a ruler of Egypt that's
Rama Tut that's came to conquer becoming
ramatut when you ended up going to limbo
and started calling yourself immortus
that was Kane the conquer and in the
future when you go into the past and
meet with your younger self to try to
get your younger self to ensure they
become you that's iron a lot that's how
all those things work together having
said that I don't know how else to
explain it besides that if that can't
explain Kane the Conqueror for you
nothing can either that or I'm just that
bad at it having said all that spent the
last six minutes explaining that let's
get into the comic the reason why you
guys are here if I haven't lost half of
you already so here's the thing what
this does is it initially picks up with
Nathaniel Richards in the 31st century
and what he says here is he says life at
this point in time really just kind of
sucks it's very very drab and very very
boring he says by the time he'd reached
the age of 18 he had conquered nothing
that his world was a Utopia of pleasure
and entertainment that is so-called
Bettors called it post-scarcity he
called it bored a Utopia to be sure
where 10 year olds could Master Advanced
robotics where a boy could have his
throat cut by bullies and recover in a
matter of months which is actually what
happened to him but it was also a place
where time seemed to stop that it was
the end of History a meaningless
procession of tepid moments a countdown
to nothing that while this Utopia is
beneficial for society as a whole in the
sense that nobody wants for anything
there is truth to the statement conflict
is in one way what gives people purpose
but is also what drives them to become
better that if people reach a point
where there is no conflict where there's
no struggling or no suffering or no pain
nobody will have a reason to improve
themselves because everybody will have
everything that they want and in the
face of that what you would likely run
into is a situation of stagnation now
whether that would happen in the real
world or not I have no idea but it's
what happened to Silver Surfers planet
is what happened to the people of Zin
law they stop focusing on religion
started focusing on science they
explored everything there was to explore
in the universe they cured every illness
that could possibly plague their people
they understood everything perfectly and
suddenly there was no more reason to
live because they had it all figured out
they had the answer to everything the
purpose behind life simply ceased to
exist and so what you end up getting is
basically Nathaniel who goes on this
kind of personal Quest where he
literally just starts traveling to these
old places that had long since been
forgotten and in a lot of ways we're
kind of off limits to the average person
but what he longed for was Adventure
what he longed for was the this kind of
bygone age you know in an era that he
was nostalgic for this despite the fact
that he never lived in it he was kind of
looking to this time when there were
straight up Heroes and there were
straight up villains all that kind of
stuff Fantastic Four Doctor Doom The
Avengers whoever in the hell else they
happen to be fighting all kinds of
things and so what he ends up doing and
going to this Museum he actually ends up
stumbling across a doom bot and that's
kind of the crazy thing is because
remember Dr Doom by this point is long
since dead and it's kind of a crazy
thing because one of the big questions
people have when it comes to Nathaniel
Richards is who is he related to because
Marvel's played it both ways they've
said that Nathaniel Richards is
descended from Victor Von Doom but
they've also said Nathaniel Richards is
is descended from Reed Richards well
maybe not necessarily said that but it's
kind of been sort of alluded to over the
years and so that's kind of a funny
thing because contextually we kind of
get an answer here that when this
doombot activates because it's just one
of the creations of Victor Von Doom
designed to stand the test of time when
it activates and starts attacking him
then of course this leads to King the
Conqueror showing up hang as we know him
showing up here destroying the a doombot
and then of course the kid saying like
who in the world are you right like you
need to answer me I am descended from
and then of course the whole thing gets
cut off now that's where contextually we
could argue that he is descended from
Victor Von do the problem here is that
if he was it's very likely that doombot
would have obeyed him when he told the
doombot to stop so again it's one of
those things where we kind of get an
answer and we kind of don't models never
really solidified it and to be honest
with you guys I don't think they ever
will I don't think Marvel will ever give
us a definitive answer as to whether or
not Kang is the the you know progeny or
the descendant of Reed or Victor I don't
think we'll ever get an answer but it's
kind of a cool thing there is because
ultimately where the two of them have
this kind of conversation came the
Conqueror approaches this from saying
like your voice is embarrassing right
like there is no easier place to lie
than in the pages of a book you'll learn
to trust only first-hand sources though
I suppose compared to the gruel that's
been that you've been raised on in this
place this would appear to be a Feast so
let me ask you would you rather read
history or would you rather make history
and so the Allure of this adventure the
Allure of being able to actually go and
live these Adventures that he'd spent so
much time reading about that's what
draws the interest of Nathaniel Richards
and so at the end you know of course in
this conversation Nathaniel's like are
you kidding me right like that's the
only thing I want this world is so thin
it's like there's absolutely nothing
here and I want everything and so the
response of King is good that means
you're ready so now ask your question
again but ask it with conviction and the
kid says who are you and this guy you
know King responds and says it's I've
been called a thousand things right ten
thousand different names by all these
different worlds that I've conquered and
so on and so forth like I've been called
a conqueror I've been called The Eternal
the god Pharaoh Rama Tut The Time Keeper
immortus but despite all of them there's
only one name that truly Rings true and
that's King the Conqueror and so he says
in the beginning before all of it I was
you and so it's an amazing conversation
that happens here because he says
through this doorway is an infinite
number of times and worlds eras that
sing my name and praise planets that
worship me but to earn those I have
known loss defeat and frustration he
says I would save you that trauma and
all of that time join me and own the
mysteries of the cosmos join me and
become king the Conqueror and so in the
end it doesn't take a whole lot to
convince Nathaniel the world he's in is
so boring and it's so basic and it's so
simple that in the end he's like
absolutely right so he immediately joins
him on this Quest and what happens the
first stop is King takes him to 65
million years before Common Era the age
of the dinosaurs specifically one year
before the asteroid hits that wipes out
all the dinosaurs on earth and what Kane
says is like this is your first lesson
right time means nothing to kink like
yes I'm dropping you off here and yes
you have a year to become you but you
think that way because your thing
thinking two dimensionally in a
three-dimensional world right like it's
it's a it's an interesting concept right
like people trying to make it in the
real world how do I succeed become
successful and wealthy in the real world
I know by working for someone else and
that's not true it's thinking
two-dimensionally in a three-dimensional
world you have to think outside the box
what can you do on your own that can
make you better absent the influence and
the need of other individuals out there
can you build a world for yourself or
are you satisfied in living in someone
else's and so that's the cool thing here
is because what Kang says and this is
one of the most important things that he
says it's easy to overlook it's easy to
not take seriously but one of the things
he says is he says many of my memories
are fogged by the ways of time centuries
of conflicting timelines playing tricks
in my head but I remember every one of
those first days with Clarity my lessons
began with survival strengthening my
body and mind where I could not
strengthen it myself Kang did so for me
now the reason why this matters and this
kind of goes back to our initial
explanation of why it was so necessary
involving immortus and andromatot and
all those different guys is because
whenever Kang went back in time and
fashioned a life for himself he became
that person he became that person that
he was pretending to be and so here's
what I want you to do right in order to
truly understand how this impacts Hank
here's what I want you to do I want you
to put in the comments or at least tell
me what did you have for dinner on
January 26
2019. you can't tell me and if you did
tell me I would probably just think you
were lying just making something up in
order to be like yup I remember
everything no nobody remembers that that
singular moment there right now that's a
couple years ago and if I if I change
that question and said what'd you have
for dinner on Monday last week you'd be
able to give me a much better guess but
instead of this being two years ago
let's pretend it's ten thousand years
ago and a life that you lived for 90
years that's what Kane contends with
that's the issue that he has and that's
why often times in comics you'll see
Kang come across immortus or iron lad or
something like that and it'll almost be
like their completely different people
because why all standards the
measurement they basically are right
like imagine you went back in time 50
years and lived out an entire life and
then at the end of that life came back
to the Modern Age and then just lived
for another Thousand Years here after a
while you wouldn't really even remember
what that what that lifetime was like
when you went back 50 years ago but it
does exist and that version of yourself
is there so it's just one of those those
weird and interesting things about
kangits why you do have different
variations of himself but they're also
starkly different in the end though this
cycle always continues right it's like
Battlestar Galactica all of this has
happened before and all of this will
happen again that Kang always becomes
king and King always goes and finds his
younger self and always leads his
younger self to become king the
exception is Iron Lab but at the end of
the day the argument still stands that
iron lad will inevitably become king the
Conqueror so it's one of these things
where he talks about whenever he says
king showed me this just imagine this
cycle as it happens right now except
this young Nathaniel Richards grows up
to be this adult Kang and this adult
Kang is basically reliving or retelling
his experiences as you see them here
he's basically recalling the life that
we're gonna see this young Nathaniel
Richards live over the course of this
comic it's very meta textual but that's
why it's so loopy that's why it goes in
circles and cycles and so that's why as
as young Nathaniel is talking about all
this he says Kane showed me our life as
a pharaoh of Egypt and taught me its
lesson and he laid bare the rules of
time which lit my mind Ablaze he says
his lessons were brutal and he says I
was proud when I overcame them as I was
proud of what we would build together he
taught me to shoot he taught me to kill
he taught me that a plan no matter how
meticulous only serves to make you weak
he forced me just as he promised but as
I was forged so did I Glimpse the flaws
in the iron that made my teacher now
this is an important thing because one
of the things that you usually see when
it comes to Kane the Conqueror is him
showing up on the scene doing some stuff
all kinds of Hell unleashing conflict
unfolding and that's basically it you
never really get to see the
interpersonal side of Ken the part of
Kang that struggles because one of the
things he says is he says that once Kane
got so drunk that he could barely stand
and he took me to a far-off world where
he cried in the shadows as a woman died
he said one word then was silent for
days that word being revok right of
course ravana rensslayer now the thing
of the thing about this the reason why
it matters is because ravana rinselayer
was the love interests of Kane the
Conqueror and she died right King's life
literally fell apart when that happened
in fact the way that Marvel wrote that
it was almost kind of a question of will
King ever recover from this it was
focusing on that interpersonal side but
you don't really see it all that often
and of course even Kang made Nathaniel
swear he would never bring it up right
like he would never mention it or
anything along those lines and so what
happens as he goes through this period
right again back in the 65 million years
that he's here as he goes through all of
that of course he ends up facing off
against you know some Tyrannosaurus Rex
which is awesome blah acid with some
with a massive gun that literally blows
this thing's head off and what he says
is this is this is where things are
really really fascinating and he says he
would love to say that in the aftermath
of killing this T-Rex that he feasted on
dinosaur meat for days and he sharpened
its teeth into knives right that he
somehow honed his skills became this
brutal Warrior that could live off the
land but he says that never happened and
the reason why is because by the time I
killed this thing all I saw was her all
I saw was this one person right this One
Singular individual and like that she
had the complete and total attention of
Kang he never had a chance right
Nathaniel was just smitten for this
woman and what was more interesting than
this is that in the society that he came
from physical touch didn't happen you
never physically touched people it was
always done as a kind of synthesis right
a kind of uh you know barrier between
you and somebody else is a way to like
prevent disease illness different things
like that and so for the first real time
in his life he's experiencing tactile
contact with an another human being more
so than that he's experiencing love he's
experiencing desire he's having all
these feelings that he's never quite
really been through before and so having
this kind of experience with her in a
lot of ways I wouldn't go as far as to
say she's in love with him and I would
even go as far as to say he's not
necessarily in love with her if anything
it's more passing curiosity now that
will change that will inevitably change
but of course she kind of invites him to
her tribe and so of course he ends up
basically chasing her down following her
to that location and he's taken before
the people here now what's kind of
baffling is that from Nathaniel
Richard's perspective there shouldn't be
any human beings here now I use that
based on the real world right that like
uh primitive human beings appeared maybe
something around 300 000 years ago that
the anatomical version of ourselves that
exists now is probably about 200 000
years ago and then over time our minds
just progress to where we are right now
uh in Marvel Comics one thing to know is
that when it comes to the evolution of
the human race we're not really given
anything before the arrival of the
Celeste it's like even in Marvel Comics
they don't do that the closest that we
ever really got in terms of those early
days is maybe a little bit of discussion
about proto-mutants uh with Gabriel
Shepard the old stories with uh not
really old story I guess they are now
Jesus I'm old 20-something year old
stories 21 year old stories by Grant
Morrison
with new X-Men she she's my mold
Christ
in any event
um we're not really given an actual
origin point for when Modern Man first
appeared in Marvel Comics so I could
almost guarantee though it wasn't 65
million years ago and this race as is
being told right this girl Addie and her
race we're not really given any
information so we don't really know if
like their time displaced or anything
like that they certainly don't act like
it but Nathanael is brought before the
lasting piece which is basically their
Elder right the the leader of the tribe
who kind of gives us this perception
that he knows who Nathaniel Richards is
going to become but he doesn't know he's
going to become king if anything it's
more of his actions that demonstrate who
he is as a person the fact that he saved
Addy's life from a dinosaur the fact
that he killed the dinosaur basically
shows that he is a person of conviction
and strength and as a result he's
brought into the tribe and honored as a
Warrior by basically being given face
paint now the other part of this is that
the tribe again because they're
primitive relies on you know prophecies
from the stars and different things like
that so they're very much given to
Superstition right this kind of a thing
and of course according to the
prophecies handed down from the elders
you know presumably the ones that came
before the lasting peace and by the
lasting peace himself they're doomed to
be destroyed by a star right by like
literally a meteor crashing into Earth
they don't really know that's what it is
but that's basically what it is and so
the thing about this is that the
Nathaniel flees to Cain the Conqueror
and says we have the ability to
manipulate time Neil time does not
matter to us so let's just take them
somewhere else let's take them to a
future right we can just snatch them up
while they're sleeping or whatever it is
but we can take them to you know some
period when the earth is habitable again
and then go from there now this is one
of the most important things that goes
on with this new origin of Kane the
Conqueror Kane the conqueror's concern
is not a disruption of the time streak
the reality is that it would right most
likely the destruction of this race
serves some purpose along the timeline
right their bones are discovered or
something like that somebody makes some
kind of a discovery which leads them
down some path where they do some things
and then that leads to them becoming a
superhero and changes the entire course
of stuff who knows but we regardless
like you can't necessarily medal with
the time stream in that way and so what
happens here is that when Nathaniel runs
to King and asks like are you awake the
response of Kang is that no it is you
who's not awake right your you dream the
naive dreams of Heroes the romance of
Alexander the purity of Steve Rogers you
will unlearn this sentimentality never
disappear from my sight again you will
do as you are ordered you will learn the
lessons I teach and never disregard them
and above all else you will wipe that
pathetic paint off of your face and the
response of Nathaniel is no that's not
going to happen and so as an answer to
this King simply says I do not make
requests right you are here by my design
and shall behave by my design your
future lies in the balance heed me or be
doomed to a life of failure of rot and
Toil and insignificance and that's when
Nathaniel's like but that's the point
you're the one who's failed you talk
endlessly about conquest and Glory but
you're just a drunk who makes me
remember rise his defeats how Doom
tricked you at the fall of Manhattan how
the Fantastic Four laid you low in the
Sands of Egypt and so this is kind of
back and forth argument and in the end
Nathanael says my life is my own it's
out there living on without me and the
people of that tribe we can save them
from the coming cataclysm if time means
nothing to us then why can't I use it to
save the first and last in this blasted
world and in the end the response of
Kang is you believe that because you're
in love and it's that love that makes
you weak it's that love that takes away
any measure of strength that you can
have that's the stance that King has his
sentimentality the fact that he's
experienced love and kindness and
romance he sees that as a weakness he
sees it as the thing that it always held
him back that if he could go back in
time and he could alter that younger
version of himself so that he didn't
experience love that that sentimentality
was stamped out of him then those
weaknesses would never come to fruition
in those moments when he hesitated
instead of killing the Fantastic Four
due to some sentimentality or some
statement made by Reed or Susan or
something like that right like who's
going to take care of our children that
if that sentimentality wasn't there he
would have pulled the trigger without
hesitation that cruelty would have
dominated and so in order to try to
demonstrate this he drags Nathaniel to
the camp when Nathaniel says I will save
them the response of King is no boy you
did not and opens fire on the place just
incinerates kills everybody there every
single person dies right they're
completely and totally killed and
Nathaniel can do nothing more than just
sit there and watch now this is hugely
important because what he says is it was
then that I understood though I had
crossed the fabric of space and time I
had never left my cage at all it was
then that I saw the cage was King and so
what he did is he basically made this
promise to himself that he wouldn't
become king he says and so for the final
months of the Cretaceous I pretended to
study that which king instructor while
secretly I studied the lock how the
mention of ravana might drive my Jailer
to drink how a few herbs might
intoxicate a glass of wine how the armor
that had opened the way might be mine to
command I'd rarely been as tempted as I
was in that moment to take the
inevitable into my own hands but his
words echoed in my ear time would
conquer all my enemies if only I could
Master it and so literally it almost
appears on the surface this is how King
becomes iron lad but that doesn't
necessarily seem to be the case instead
as this meteor comes crashing down into
the world with the intention of
destroying it and basically leading to
the end of all things he ultimately ends
up walking away travels through a time
portal and when he does he finds himself
in the realm of Rama Tut what this does
is this takes place during the era of
what is essentially Rama Tut now that's
where things get a little murky because
when he shows up here is essentially a
giant battle taking place now this
battle is between and somebody else who
we'll talk about here in a little bit
but on this battlefield is effectively a
Moon Knight now one of the reasons why
Colin Kelly's able to pull this off is
because as you guys know just from the
history of Moon Knight and Marvel Comics
it wasn't really until Mark Spector was
taken to the Statue of konshu that the
world got its first Moon knife over the
years and really when I say over the
years I mean more recently in Marvel
Comics that's been changed right it's
kind of been a big red con to
essentially say there have been
different avatars of konshu on Earth in
the form of a Moon Knight that came
before Mark Spector and it's not
uncommon for Marvel to do that for years
for example Danny Rand was the only Iron
Fist and then we got Orson Randall who
was the iron fist before Danny ran and
there were a whole bunch of iron fists
before Orson Randall it had just gone on
that way the idea of there being Moon
Knights that took place or existed
before Mark Spector that was largely the
result of Jason Aaron and his run on
Avengers specifically with Avengers 1
million so basically this idea that
there was an Avengers team that existed
one million years before the modern era
it was largely composed of big Heavy
Hitters so like Odin the original
Phoenix Force as it existed on Earth the
first star brand the first Iron Fist the
first black panther different things
along those lines just uh kind of giving
us these different stories sometimes it
works sometimes it doesn't when it comes
to Moon Knight what you get here is
basically this version that pops up now
there isn't a whole lot of explanation
given here initially instead what ends
up happening is that this person is told
or at least Nathaniel's told by this
Moon Knight you are called by the moon
and initially when Nathaniel chases this
Moon Knight down trying to figure out
who they are or where they're going or
how all this is working that the only
thing he's really told is that the voice
of the Knight speaks only truth a hero
from Beyond time comes soon from the sky
to restore the ancient ways and end The
Pretenders Reign now this is one of the
things that we have to talk about here
is the nature of Rama Tut and why it is
that this version of Moon Knight differs
from Mark Spector so when it comes to
Rama Tut one of the things that we've
talked about before is that King the
Conqueror in his initial attempt for
Conquest had gone all the way back to
ancient Egypt and basically seized
control and because of the fact that he
had come from the 31st Century as has
been stated by different people and in
different ways that sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from Magic and so Kane the conquerors
showing up here with advanced technology
as far as the ancient Egyptians were
concerned he was a God right they were
like this guy's just capable of
incredible things this is insane right
obviously this person is a God now
pharaohs in the time of ancient Egypt
were largely considered to be avatars of
God of specifically raw or other other
individuals on Earth but they were
considered Divine in nature and so
because of that Kane kind of fit very
nicely into how Egyptians perceived
people uh specifically pharaohs and the
idea of magic and divine powers and so
that's why he sees control here now one
of the things to know is that konshu and
the various gods that existed had long
since existed here by and large konshu
doesn't really care what goes on on
Earth he's got his own scheme and his
own motivation one of the things that's
been recently asked established
especially during
um oh my God Jeff lemire's run on on
moon night is that konshu seeks to
basically find a vessel for himself to
basically rule the world hence the
reason why he had manipulated Mark
Specter and his disassociative identity
disorder in order to hollow him out
quote unquote and turn him into a vessel
that konshu could inhabit and then rule
the world so konshu and the various
other Egyptian gods don't necessarily
concern themselves with the idea that
like King the conquerors come from the
future to the Past in order to rule
ancient Egypt but one of the other
things to notice here is that this
version of Moon Knight wholly believes
and what kanchu told them and not to
sound too Brusque about it but the
reason why is because they just don't
know any better by the time Mark Spector
had become Moon Knight people were more
intelligent they were more capable and
they were more aware of how the world
exists so the idea of gods and things
like that had largely Fallen away this
takes place during that era to a degree
before the third Celestial host where
you basically had the celestial showing
up and telling the various Gods of Earth
not to to intervene in the Affairs of
mortal men it kind of follow Falls
during that that bit of a murky period
we can largely assume that maybe that's
already happened but whatever it is the
influence of gods and goddesses on
Humanity still holds strong and that's
why this person who became Moon Knight
hears the voice of konshu and takes it
as an absolute truth because by the time
Mark Spector came around in the 20th
century the idea of people believing in
Gods sure it was there but they didn't
believe it with the same veracity right
they didn't believe it with the same
absolute belief system it was like uh
you know people believed in the idea of
God because they were more afraid of the
consequences of not believing than the
actual benefit of believing if there is
one and so as the two of them talk when
it comes to Nathaniel remember he knows
the entire history of Earth and so what
he says is he says far be it for me to
argue with my savior but Rama Todd isn't
someone you can just hope to overthrow
trust me I've studied him for years and
the response to this person is he's
Enslaved the entirety of creation now as
somebody who's never left Egypt as far
as they're concerned Egypt is all of
creation and the the in influence of of
Rama Tut just stretches into Infinity
now of course that's not the case and
Nathaniel says it's only really Egypt
but like that's plenty of stuff to rule
he says it's his War Machine against my
broken suit of armor I'm sorry lady but
I'm not the hero that you're looking for
you're thinking of Reed Richards now the
reason why this matters and I love that
Colin Kelly did this is because in the
original story when Rama Tut first
appeared in in Marvel Comics The
Fantastic Four traveled back to Egypt
defeated ramatut and forced him to
travel back to his timeline right they
defeated that version of King now again
as we discussed along the way back to
his timeline he ended up in the true
limbo became a mortise and then there's
kind of a splinter timeline where he
ended up going back and becoming kanked
but the AL the the reality here is that
what you're doing or at least what Colin
Kelly's doing is he's basically keeping
the continuity of the history of Rama
Tut intact but adding to it which is a
really cool thing that's a pretty
beneficial thing and a very important
thing but what goes on here is
ultimately Nathaniel is taken to the
Temple of konshu and is basically told
like talk to talk to kanchu itself and
find out if there's any real truth here
the reality though is that Nathaniel
doesn't really believe in Gods I mean he
knows that they've existed but they're
not all powerful beings they don't
really exist in the capacity the way
that this this Moon Knight believes they
do that they are just people that are
out there and they can be killed and so
as a result of that Nathaniel really
views God as more of just really
powerful beings as opposed to these
Divine individuals beyond the
understanding of humanity and with a
power that just simply can't be matched
the only real God that exists out there
in Marvel Comics in that capacity is the
one above all everybody else can just be
killed it just takes differing levels of
power to do it the Living Tribunal was
killed by the beyonders the other Cosmic
entities as well and the different
Cosmic entities have been destroyed by
different beings depending on what era
of comics you're talking about if you're
looking at Al Ewing's ultimates that the
uh that eternity was basically defeated
and not really killed but overpowered by
like the first firmament right the
sentience of the first universe so it
gets a little meta and it gets a little
wonky but as the two of them continue
talking what ends up going on is that
this person reveals their identity to
Nathaniel Richards and we end up finding
out this Moon Knight is actually ravana
rensslayer now here's the thing to
understand here and this is why I say
from this point going forward the entire
history of ravana rensslayer is going to
be completely Rewritten or at least her
origin is going to be completely
Rewritten the original origin of ravana
rinselayer is she's from the 40th
century and that you ended up having a
time where Kane the Conqueror had
arrived there but ultimately spared the
place because he was in love with her
and then it was a kind of love-hate
relationship where they loved each other
then they hated each other she killed
him a couple times
they were just one of those things there
was literally a point where she
resurrected him just to kill him it was
it's kind of nuts right it was that
level of hate and disdain but it was
very much a love hate if anything a
passionate relationship between the two
what it looks like Colin Kelly's doing
is reworking the entirety of that by
introducing ravana rensslayer here and
saying she is a Moon Knight and then
presenting her to us in this way what it
looks like is this is where ravana
rensslayer starts this is where her
origin begins instead of it being in the
40th Century she was just a person in
Egypt and ended up becoming a host for
kanchu as the first Moon Knight or one
of the Moon Knights presumably the
second moon night after Avengers 1
million and she just kind of goes
forward from there but again things will
be explained as time effectively goes on
because we'll actually see different
versions of her in different points in
time across this story so it'll be a
little murky to a degree not gonna lie a
little ambiguous there but at the end of
the day she presents herself as a person
that wholeheartedly believes in the idea
of konshu and what ends up happening is
Nathaniel kind of says I do not believe
in Gods in my life of Conquest I have
crushed countless Divine skulls in my
hands but even before I saw fear in the
eyes of the god of thunder and yet he
recalls those thoughts by Kang never
love and he says in that place my mind
ran clear the past the future like a
river of blood from my mind to King's
neurokinetic armor time and memory
coursed through my veins I swore that I
would be the hero she saw in me I swore
to tear him down as she says in the
shadow of a dead God I took my revenge
and cast it in iron and so what this
says and this isn't necessarily
something that's absolutely solidified
in the modern era what this says is that
this younger version of Kang basically
becomes the first Iron lad now I say
that as if there's more than one iron
light I mean I guess technically there
kind of is but not necessarily the
reality here is that in the end it is
all King right so this kind of origin
still Rings True by the origin of King
but one of the things to know is that in
the old school or not really old school
but in the Young Avengers story that the
idea of iron lad was basically a younger
version of Kang that didn't want to
become king and did everything he could
not to become king but in the end every
origin of everybody stems from Kang in
the 30th and 31st centuries and so
because of that they are all destined to
become king eventually immortus goes on
to become king iron lad goes on to
become king everybody originates from
Kang because he was a guy that basically
went back in time and initially started
it all and that's why if you look at
characters like Kane the Conqueror or
even like uh reverse flash eobard Thon
in DC Comics the reason why they're
basically indestructible in the sense
that you can never truly kill them is
because they effectively exist
simultaneously at different points in
time and so because they exist at
different points in time they can always
reappear at any point in time so imagine
you for example traveled back to I don't
know like the first century right just
some arbitrary point in time uh you
exist in the first century but because
we have Branch universe theory there's
also a reality or a timeline where you
never traveled back in time and so if
somebody were to go to that point where
you quote unquote went back in time uh
and they stopped you the moment before
you did and they killed you then what
that would mean is you would still exist
in the first century you would still be
there instead there is a branch universe
that exists out there now where you died
before you could go back in time so you
could never truly kill that person it's
one of those things where in in Marvel
and even DC Comics once a person learns
the ability to travel through the time
stream the instant they make their first
attempt or their first travel through
time they can never truly be destroyed
now they can always just reappear at any
point in time so it's really kind of
murky and it's really is it's very very
ambiguous and I know when it comes to
time travel it can be a little confusing
but it's essentially a way to unlock
immortality using technological means
but the result of this is that as iron
lad really the first time he becomes
this character he basically ends up
helping the forces of of Moon Knight and
this what seems to be this Rebel faction
facing off against Rama Tut and trying
to bring down his Rule now the reality
of this and what's really really cool is
that in these various battles of their
part of there is a larger Force pulling
the strings when it comes to these
forces that are trying to destroy or
bring down Kane to conquer we'll get to
them here in a second although I imagine
some of you guys have already guessed
who that person is one of the greatest
characters of all time
whom I absolutely love uh but one of the
things to know is that as these battles
are fought that it's really more of a
series of battles as part of a
continuous war and as you know battles
end and so in these bits of LOLs there's
a very deep and personal connection
that's formed between Nathaniel and
ravana rensslayer and it's kind of
interesting because she asked the
question in the place that you come from
is this place remembered and he says in
the time that I come from everything is
remembered imperfectly and through the
lens of the victors perhaps but
remembered all the same that was the
problem when everything's been done
before you what can your life possibly
be worth but I knew I was destined for
more even before Kane came to visit me I
knew and the response so ravana is I
have never known a life without Destiny
I remember nothing before it my parents
were the will of konshu and they have
long ago vanished into the sunlight of
my memory if they were ever there at all
and the response here is that Nathaniel
asks did he give you your name your God
and her response is no my name has
always been but he did give me yours and
that's when she says like I was told you
were coming here but in this moment he
recalls the words that King had spoken
to him when he was effectively trying to
rid him of weakness and saying never
love lest you be conquered but the
thought of Nathanael here is but he knew
nothing of love I was absolutely sure he
was a creature of hate when you are
young it is so hard to see that one is
only born from the other that without
love to inspire it hate is simply just
rage anger can be conquered by calm but
like its pathetic cousin regret hatred
just feeds it makes one ruthless it
drives the preparation of armories and
the shattering of centuries it
intertwines with the power of a parasite
around the brain stem love makes one
blind as hatred makes one see and it is
in that way that we fell under his eye
what nathanael's really saying here is
that when it comes to the ideas of love
and hate they really are intertwined
Kang hates the person he became because
he experienced love because he fell in
love with ravana rensslayer and he saw
that idea of love as the thing that made
him weak that rage is directionless Rage
has no real drive or ambition is a thing
that exists as a byproduct of
experiences things that have maybe
happened to you but it's not necessarily
born in love but love is is an intensely
positive emotion and I would argue the
most positive emotion hate can be born
out of love which drives you to the most
negative emotion the reality here is
that he sees Kang as becoming the person
he did because he experienced love but
in his desire to refuse to become king
he Embraces love he sees love and in
fact that's where he and ravana
rinslayer effectively fall in love now
again this is why I say this new origin
of ravana rinselayer is a little
ambiguous here because the answer she
gives Nathaniel on her origin are cloak
and dagger at best right and it may just
be smoke and mirrors she's like well
I've always had my name maybe it's a
name that was given to me by my parents
but I don't really even know if my
parents existed anymore right their
memory the memory of them is basically
gone and it's one of those weird things
because you would think that for a
person her age which you know just going
on the way she's drawn looks to be maybe
in her late 20s early 30s she would very
definitely remember her parents but the
idea here is that potentially her
parents may have died and when she was
at a very young age in which case it may
be one of those things where her memory
just doesn't really recall a lot of her
parents because she was so young when
they died there's no definitive answers
given here but you could look at it from
a different perspective and say she's
very much like Rama Tut she basically
came here at some past point in time and
she came here from the future because of
all the different adventures in
escapades she'd gone on but at the end
of the day uh she's just fall in the
same path as Rama Tut she doesn't
remember a whole lot about herself but
what goes on is that once the two of
them are captured and they're brought
before Rama Tut that initially Rama's
HUD actually ends up blasting uh ravana
rensslayer with what's known as the
ultra diode Ray and it's basically a
weapon well used by Kane the conquerors
how he ensnared a lot of the people
under his service and basically forces
her into a position of of being a a
subject right it takes away her
willpower and in fact that seemed to be
the way in which she was able to form
his initial higher counsel and then in
turn position himself as a god king now
the response to Nathaniel is of course
to lash out one part because he's in
love with her and two because he knows
that Rama's Hut is King from a different
point in time now remember as time would
pass Kane the Conqueror in Ram UT would
eventually become their own distinct
personalities but Rama Tut does remember
his his idea or remember him being Kang
at one point in time and so that's why
he he kind of recognizes Nathaniel
Richards to a degree and so far as like
iron lad different things like that but
he doesn't have any memory of of this
sort of encounter taking place because
it's never happened before or at least
it doesn't seem to have happened before
one of the big issues is that King's
entire history is a Time Loop and so
seemingly this has happened before it's
just for whatever reason every time
feels like the first time which is kind
of weird I know it's we're never going
to go into that because it just seems
wonky it just seems really really meta
and honestly would just take too long to
explain uh but at the end of the day
Rama type really says like I have no
memory of this right a Divergent
timeline perhaps some kind of a variant
or a new Loop whatever it is what this
means is that killing you would no more
affect me than the destruction of an
alien son and the response that
Nathaniel is smart here he says but Rama
Todd is a footnote in our story barely
even a prologue you don't even know our
true name I would think very hard before
you execute me the throat you slit may
very well be your own that means Kane
the Conqueror will never come into
existence and if Kane the Conqueror
never comes into existence there's no
one to come back in time and to be you
now the reality here is that Colin Kelly
is jumping back and forth between a
linear timeline and Branch universe
theory the reality here is based on
Marvel's Branch universe theory if
Rama's Hut were to kill uh basically
iron lad it wouldn't make any difference
it would have no real involvement in any
real capacity whatsoever it would just
be a thing that happens and that would
basically be it uh that's kind of how
that Branch universe theory concept
Works in Marvel Comics but at the end of
the day what he says is you know what
you're absolutely right here uh you know
killing you is too much of a risk
however using you is a great strategy
because you're technologically advanced
you have access to essentially all my
resources and even some of the resources
that I don't have access to so we'll
turn you into a servant instead of
killing you and so by blasting him he
basically turns him into what is in
effect the first Scarlet Centurion now
one of the big differences between this
and Comics is they were originally
written is that when Kane the Conqueror
was on his way back to his time stream
he did end up arriving in the modern era
due to a Time storm and encountered
Doctor Doom and their first encounter
and someone inspired by Dr armor
basically Kane got rid of the Rama Tut
guys and then basically started calling
himself a Scarlet Centurion of course
again that was covered in what was
covered in a few different places it was
like Avengers annual number two God it
was like Captain America annual number
11. and I want to say it was in
Fantastic Four no it wasn't it was a
what if story I don't remember the exact
issue of the what if story I think it
was issue number two yeah it was what if
issue number 29 um did all this stuff
was basically explained and and whatnot
but the thing behind this is that giving
us this indication as the first Scarlet
Centurion what it does is it sets the
stage for the idea that in a lot of ways
came to conquer just kind of inspired
himself to become the people that he was
but making Nathaniel into Scala
Centurion he ends up leading the forces
of Kane to conquer albeit against his
will against the force that is
controlling all these individuals out
there that are fighting against the rule
of of ramatud and trying to conquer his
kingdom of course all of them being led
by apocalypse which I love now this is
one of the things where Colin Kelly is
basically kind of blowing off the old
Adventures of Cyclops in Phoenix which
is where you got the initial origin of
Apocalypse where basically he was rising
to power around the same time that a
ramatut Was Defeated and the way he's
depicted in this comic he's already in
possession of celestial technology that
hadn't happened yet in the old school
story so basically it's calling Kelly
kind of rewriting the history of
Apocalypse to a degree which is fine the
origin of Apocalypse I mean it's there
but I never really took it as an
absolute truth and it's one of those
things where anybody could rewrite it in
virtually any way and it's fine if they
did for the most part people don't
really care about apocalypse before he
became apocalypse they care about him
after he became apocalypse because
that's when he got awesome right so it's
cool to see him leading this Force now
of course with Apocalypse at what is in
effect the height of his power because
once he achieved this level his power
never really increased he was just at
this state for seemingly thousands of
years before the modern era but the
thing about this is that at this point
in time he's wildly powerful and wildly
capable but in the end the battle is a
pretty severe and extreme battle and so
what Nathaniel says it was is that it
was in those days that I first knew War
I learned the way of scream sounds when
it is someone's last and how fear alone
can stop a heartbeat even before death
love made me blonde and so I began to
hate I saw the only path forward my body
was a prison my armor a cage to escape
King's power both needed to be broken
and he says and through the pain I swore
I will have revenge on King I will have
revenge on King and he's and that's the
thing he keeps saying to motivate
himself and that's the thing he kept
saying to remind himself now by the time
he gets back to the Citadel of King
where King is basically operating that's
when he sees the Fantastic Four fighting
against Kang and then ultimately pushing
him back to his timeline and of course
that's how his history kind of unfolds
the original Scarlet Centurion as we
initially saw him in the old Fantastic
Four comics and so on and so forth but
the reality here is he says that within
a day of ramatut's Escape into the time
stream his kingdom fell to chaos that
apocalypse took all he wished and burned
the remnants no record of ravana Rim
Slayer like a footprint in the Sands of
the desert she was scattered to touch I
told myself a lie in those days none are
lost in the light of the moon but I knew
better than to believe it she was As
Dead As the God she served but Kang was
still alive and so that's why things
were a little murky here is because
again maybe ravana rinslayer comes from
the future she went to the Past she
basically forgot her own history and
believes she had always just existed
there and then became a Moon Knight it's
one of those things that we'll explore
as the story goes on but the Final Act
in basically trying to get back to his
time because in effect he doesn't really
have the same level of technology that
he used to have he's stuck in his
Scarlet Centurion suit is he goes to the
only person who has a level of power
that could get him through the time
stream he goes to apocalypse and he
simply says together we can destroy Kang
the Conqueror I was reading over the
comments of the previous videos after I
got back and I noticed that some of you
guys were a little confused in terms of
how the whole Kane the Conqueror thing
works and all that kind of stuff okay so
as you guys know when it comes to Marvel
Comics the main Marvel universe is Earth
616 right that's well established you
guys have all pretty much known that for
quite some time what you have is you do
have a Nathaniel Richards from earth616
but that is the Nathaniel Richards known
as the father of Reed Richard so if you
ever read Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic
Four run that's Nathaniel right now he
does have time traveling escapades and
so on and so forth and he was part of
Kang War different things along those
lines but when you think of King the
Conqueror right Prime King if you want
to call him that the main cane the
Conqueror who goes back in time and
fights the Avengers and all that kind of
stuff he comes from a reality called
Earth 6311. this story as it's being
told is basically the origin of King the
difference here is that unlike what a
lot of the stuff that you've read before
it's designed to basically rework his
origin slightly as well as massively
rework character like ravana rensslayer
and the reason for that is because
coming out of the Loki TV show ravana
rensslayer is a very popular character
or at least pretty popular way more than
she ever was in the comics and so there
was a lot of confusion with her
character in the comics if Loki had
literally ended and said for more about
ravana run Slayer go read Marvel Comics
as she exists right now it would confuse
the piss out of people they would have
no idea where to start or which version
of her it is or anything like that it
was it was just it was a massively
complicated thing right she was just
kind of thrown in there with a time
traveling escapades of Kang and there
was no real explanation given insofar as
how it all ties together this story
corrects that the other part of that is
that where this story focused on
answering the question this idea that
when Kane to conquer was a teenager some
future version of himself just showed up
and said I'm going to turn you into me
that we're either focused on younger
Kang trying not to become his older self
this video right here is where
everything begins to shift so in the
last video that we covered we had
basically talked about how there was a
it was really younger King ending up in
ancient Egypt and coming across Rama Tut
who as you guys know was Kane the
Conqueror going back to ancient Egypt
and then basically trying to rule there
and then conquer the Earth from that
point going forward ultimately though
there was a great big war taking place
between uh Kane the Conqueror and
apocalypse and so as a result of that
what you ended up having was younger
King who basically Allied himself with
what appeared to be ravana rinselayer in
ancient Egypt and then in turn helping
uh helping apocalypse fend off and
really defeat the forces of ramatud of
course with King basically fleeing back
to his present after being defeated by
The Fantastic Four who had time travel
to that time period again we had covered
more of that in the video so that's a
little confusing to you I invite you to
go back and check out that video the
thing about it is that after that whole
conflict is ended right that adult Kang
fled back to his own time and all you're
left with is younger Kang here in that
whole series of events that whole
Calamity ravana rinselayer had
effectively died and so as a result of
that because ravana rensslayer had
basically appeared intermittently
throughout the time stream and really
defied anything regarding like the laws
of Aging or anything like that and no
explanation has been given yet which we
will we'll get an explanation on that um
basically you have young Kang who's in
love with Pravana rensslayer he has a
vendetta against his older self and then
he also wants to find a way to save
ravana so what he ends up doing is
making a deal with Apocalypse Now as you
guys know apocalypse as a villain this
guy's nothing if not just beholden to
Evolution right the Guy believes in
Social Darwin is of only the strongest
deserve to survive it's one of the
reasons why apocalypse is a little
hypocritical in some ways on one hand
he'll make these grandiose speeches
about how Evolution will have its do and
only those who who are able to deal with
you know strength and and show how
capable they are are the ones who
deserve to live all the while he
basically used the techno-organic virus
as it was given to him by cable albeit
inadvertently to interface with
Celestial technology and Grant himself
all these Powers so if he was really
living up to his own belief system he
never would have done that he would have
just used whatever Powers had been
matched actually given to him to find
some way to be a conqueror so basically
it's a long way for me to say that when
it comes to his life philosophy
apocalypse is full of [ __ ] so the thing
about this is that what he does is he
tells Nathaniel like I will give you the
ability to travel forward in time right
to travel to you know your future or
whatever time period you need to go to
but you will not do it using some kind
of time machine or anything like that
you will do it at the whims and wants of
time herself and so instead of him just
being given the ability to travel into
the future by way of some sort of
machine or something like that he's
actually encased in a sarcophagus and
left there for like thousands of years
where he just kind of goes forward right
literally just sitting there in this
case now the thing about it is that that
Kang doesn't really say that this is any
kind of a torture I mean psychologically
it is to a degree but in order to keep
himself from going insane he steals
himself right he says time is a thing to
be conquered that was the edge of King's
knife not tactics nor technology nor
superpowers nor brutality time travel
but even without a machine we all travel
through time slowly and ever forward so
with my flesh protected from age by
apocalypse's Arcane technology but my
mind restlessly aware I did that one
thing that king would find aboard I took
the long way around and all the while I
sharpened my mind and steeled my focus I
had many coming victories to contemplate
but I was drawn particularly to the
failures the ones I had been trained to
prevent I contemplated ravana the
mystery of her name echoing on my Elder
self's lips and of meeting my own ravana
in the distant past I shed my Boyhood to
make myself her murderers undoing and
finally in the shadow of 26
964 years of preparation meditation and
patience I arrived and so he basically
shows up here in what's essentially the
modern era right the modern day and when
I say the modern day I mean like The
Avengers in the 1960s really is is
really what I'm referring to here but
when he arrives here here this
sarcophagus of course is discovered and
of course he ends up breaking out and so
on and so forth but as he's here of
course he overhears a news blip on the
radio from Jay Jonah Jameson where
basically there's some kind of uh UFO
right a hovercraft out there that's just
like wreaking havoc and the Avengers are
fighting it and so on and so forth and
what they don't quite know what to make
of it and in fact Jameson asks a
question like is it Invaders from outer
space Kang is like no that's my future
self who's arrived here with the
intention of attacking the Avengers team
now what's really really interesting
about this and this is what's really
really cool is that you have younger
Kang who shows up to this vessel now in
his mind he doesn't spend a whole lot of
time with the Avengers they're really
more of an afterthought here and that's
one of the things that's so cool about
this story is whenever we traditionally
read comic books The Avengers or
somebody like that they're always in
some capacity the main focus right like
here's a Spider-Man story where Peter
Parker's doing his thing and something
happens and some villain shows up you
know whatever he's really really strong
Peter can't do it on his own so here
come the Avengers and now it's a team up
book you don't really see instance is
where it's just like and there are the
Avengers over there doing something
let's go back to what it is that we're
doing here like you never really see
that all the time right and it's really
I really enjoy it's one of the things
that I loved about books like this is
it's basically Kang like younger Kang
who's like I gotta fight my older self
and it's cool to see The Avengers
because I remember seeing them when I
was a little kid way you know in the
far-flung future you know when he's from
the 31st Century but he's like I
remember seeing them as a little kid
studying about them and like the museum
and the libraries and different things
like that so it's kind of wild to
actually see them here and they kind of
look like I always imagined them in my
memory that they were much bigger than
they are you know they're just people
here who do some stuff so there is a bit
of nostalgia here but it's one of those
things where he doesn't quite have time
to sit back and Marvel at The Avengers
fighting against you know the forces of
Kane to conquer instead can't like
younger Kang ends up going into the
vessel now it's one of these things and
this is a really really important aspect
of this he says so as The Avengers
fought Kang with shield and Hammer I
approached not as Alexander but as
Odysseus I made Kings time ship know me
as as a friend for none could access its
Arsenal but K perhaps as I recall it now
that moment was the first time I was
truly him and the reason why he says
that and the reason why this is so
significant is because over the course
of this story younger Kang has been
doing everything he can to prevent
himself from becoming older King the
Conqueror from like becoming that
villain it's a cool thing here because
in the midst of this battle of course
the Avengers kind of get the upper hand
King ship is is on the verge of getting
ready to take off and younger Kang ends
up confronting older King so like the
videos that we've done in the past we'll
refer to younger King as Nathaniel and
older Kang is just King right we'll just
call him that so the thing about this is
that Kang does not recognize Nathaniel
Richards and the reason why he doesn't
recognize him is because Kang has not
met him yet now I know it sounds
confusing as hell
this is why I say King stories man you
have to really approach these carefully
like especially if you're if I'm making
a video about this I have to approach it
very very carefully because I could just
blow through it the way that we normally
do with stories it would confuse the
piss out of here so here is a super
simple explanation to why it is that
Kang does not know Nathaniel so in a
previous video we talked about how Kang
despite only being probably in his 30s
or so has traveled back and forth
Through Time a ton of times and as a
result of that you could argue he's
cumulatively lived a thousand lifetimes
and so it's very very easy to just
forget things now what's important about
this is that Kane the Conqueror at this
point in his history has not traveled
back to find his younger self and
basically train his younger self and
teach him everything he needs to know to
prevent him from losing this is the
point in the story when Kane the
Conqueror is facing off against the
Avengers and losing so he hasn't come to
this realization what if I just go back
and grab my younger self and basically
correct all my mistakes in that younger
self so when my younger self becomes me
they won't have all the flaws that I
have now they'll be a better version of
me so they never make the same mistakes
and they ultimately come out on top
right that's why Kang does not remember
Nathaniel because he hasn't met him yet
because he hasn't come up with that idea
to grab Nathaniel and teach him
everything he needs to know to ensure
that Kang does not lose in these various
fights that he engages in now the thing
about this is remember Nathaniel doesn't
want to become Kang so even though he
accesses the ship by pretending to be
king and so on and so forth he still
stands against him right and one of the
things to keep in mind is he still
Harbors a lot of love for ravana
rensslayer and he's still very very mad
about the fact that she died in ancient
Egypt because of the actions of Kang
when he was pretending or operating
under the moniker of Rama Tut and so
what he says is that his intention is to
eradicate King right to kill King Here
and Now on this ship and by doing so it
would remove him from the time stream in
his entirety at that point he would go
back into the past in ancient Egypt and
he would say saved the life of ravana
rensslayer because if he were to go back
in the past and save the life of ravana
king would always end up back there
because it's just his history he would
always become Rama tud he would always
exist in ancient Egypt and that
situation with how ravana died would
always repeat itself but if he can kill
Kang and by doing so purge him from the
time stream in its entirety then
ultimately he can go back to ancient
Egypt he can save the life of ravana
live a live a life with her and never
have to worry about Kang showing up
there to wreak havoc in any capacity
because he's dead right like there's
there's no King to travel back and forth
in time anymore and so the response of
Kang is that's insane like do you have
any idea what you would do if you did
that right like I'm so ingrained in the
time stream you would quite literally
break time itself but if I didn't exist
and you killed me it would destroy time
there has to always be a king there
needs to always be a cane to conquer
traveling back and forth Through Time
engaging in these different things
because this is how it's supposed to
work it's kind of ambiguous and it's
very meta textual in terms of How It's
explained but really it points to the
the greater argument here that in Marvel
Comics there does always have to be a
king but Kang always comes into
existence it always ends up that way I
mean I guess maybe there's a universe
out there where there is no King the
Conqueror but that Universe has never
been seen right King always exists in
every Universe across the Multiverse
seemingly every single time now what's
crazy is that in the midst of this
argument between the two suddenly
they're met by the arrival of Victor Von
Doom of Dr Doom's son now here's a cool
thing right Dr Doom would normally never
intervene here and he certainly probably
wouldn't take the risk of showing up and
confronting Kane to conquer in his own
ship where he's at his most powerful but
the opportunity is too good of a chance
to pass up that Dr Doom watching the
entire conflict between Kang and the
Avengers and even being able to see
what's going on here using sorcery and
mysticism and whatnot came to the
realization there's two kings here there
is King from the future and King King
from the past right his younger self if
he can eradicate both then ultimately it
would save Doom a lot of Hassle and
grief and Kang like standing in his way
regarding domination because one of the
things to know is that it's kind of an
unofficial competition between doom and
Kang in the sense that like Doctor Doom
wants to conquer the world but so does
Kane conquer and so they usually end up
bumping heads in terms of their various
schemes there is a kind of respect among
them it's grudging in the sense where
Doom like respects what it is a king's
capable of and Kang respects Doom then
there's also the the link that Marvel
has kind of created or teased but never
actually solidified that came to
conqueror may very well be descended
from Doctor Doom we never get a
definitive answer on that we don't know
if that's actually the case but
regardless of the situation Doom sees
this as a chance to take out two birds
with one stone and so what you have is a
massive battle that basically takes
place between the three of them to a
degree now when I say to a degree is
because it's really more Kane the
Conqueror trying to take out Doctor Doom
and then it's Nathaniel trying to reason
with king and the reason why he says
that is because he says look ultimately
the immediate thread here is Doctor Doom
but you in you know in the in your
future will come back and find me and
when you find me you're going to take me
to the through the time stream and
you're going to try to correct all the
flaws In Yourself by correcting those
flaws of me teaching me those lessons
never love different things along those
lines right love is a weakness the the
fact that you fell in love with ravana
rensslayer is what led to you becoming
as weak and incapable as you are if I
don't have any of those weaknesses I
will become ruthless in a way that you
never work I will become every ounce
conqueror but at the end of the day I
can just teach you those things myself I
come from what is in effect your future
right like I know your history I know
what happens to you like I know these
conflicts right I know what happens to
you running all the way up until like
the 31st Century so I know how your
battles with the Avengers will unfold I
know all that stuff so just let me teach
you those things right let me teach you
how you lost so that you can win and so
as a result of that the bargain is
struck the deal is made King says okay
they basically end up ejecting uh Dr
Doom from the ship using using you know
time mechanics and then once Dr Doom's
out of the picture the response of Kang
is okay let's do this and the response
of Nathaniel is no right Doom was 100
right Kang is not to be trusted your
time is done and he fires on it he
literally executes his older self right
just kills him right there and then
shoots him to death and it's just this
amazing moment where where King says
king is dead Long Live King and the
argument that he makes here what he's
basically saying is you are going to
become me there's no way you're not
there's no way you can't right like you
are doing exactly what I would have done
right like you like whether you know it
or not you are walking headlong into
this role you're walking headlong into
becoming Kang and so that's what's so
funny here because at this point once
king is dead Nathaniel says okay now I
can execute my plan I can Dawn the
moniker of Rama Tut and I can go back to
ancient Egypt and I can save the life of
ravana rensslayer I won't use the diode
raid that forces her to bend to my will
instead like I will I will conquer Egypt
right I will see my younger self so in
effect it's exactly everything that we
saw happening in the last video that we
covered it's all unfolding the
difference here is that the motivation
of ramatut is different but everything
else is the exact same what his younger
self is there so on and so forth and he
tells ravana like okay so like like
basically I'm gonna take you to a place
where I'm gonna keep you safe right I'm
going to take you to this Citadel it's
going to keep you safe everything's
gonna be fine but he still operates its
Rama Time by all Sanders and measurement
he's still a villain because it's the
role he has to play in order to save the
life of ravana you see how he's falling
down this path of becoming King right
like you see how like he's just
continually becoming this guy and that's
when the Fantastic Four show up and they
see him as Rama tut the fight unfolds
and so he says I did exactly what Kane
the Conqueror would have done right what
Rama Tut did initially I fled so
regardless of the fact that he's trying
to do things differently in the end he's
doing them the exact same way the
timeline unfolds the exact same way and
that's really the bigger Focus here is
that time is not something you can just
control and manipulate however you want
to it has a finite Form and Function it
starts at a and it ends at Z and that
there are things things that happen in
between where you can kind of fudge them
a little bit but at the end of the day
there are fixed points in the universe's
history that cannot be changed that
cannot be modified they cannot be
adjusted there are Universal constants
that have to exist in the universe King
the Conqueror is a universal constant
Rama Tut's existence is a universal
point in the time strength that cannot
be adjusted it always happens how it is
that he wants it to happen is irrelevant
but it always happens right he basically
like no matter what would take place
here no matter what his thought process
would be no matter what would happen it
would be him traveling back as Rama Tut
and he would give people science but he
would still be Ramen Tut there's no way
to escape that so what ends up happening
is once he is once he flees and gets
away as best he can he ends up in the
far-flung future and 4000 A.D and the
first person he's greeted by is ravana
rensslayer which begs the question how
did ravana RIM Slayer survive from the
days of ancient Egypt to now so in Earth
and in the 40th Century as the way that
you're seeing this play out words quote
unquote Rama taught who ends up in the
40th Century that's technically accurate
that's the way it played out in comics
originally when it came to Kane the
Conqueror the difference here is that
this version of ramatud is not the same
as the way it was originally done in
Marvel Comics hence the reason why we're
getting this change in origin that Rama
taught was the tried and true Kang
operating under the guise of ramadhut
who was ultimately defeated by The
Fantastic Four fled back to his era
ended up in the 40th century and so in
in the way the comics were originally
told it was basically a different
version of ramadath than the one that we
see here right Nathaniel his motivation
for why he did what he did when he was
ramatud was totally different him
operating as ramatut here now in the
40th century is different but again it's
Marvel basically solidifying that no
matter what Nathaniel does he will
always become king and he'll always
follow the path of the person that ends
up becoming King that is unavoidable and
there's no way to escape it the way we
know this is that when he shows up here
what he finds himself in is basically a
war-torn territory now one of the big
differences here is that in the Original
Stories the way it was told by Rama Tut
right so Avengers 269 Captain America
annual number 11 ravana rensslayer
didn't exist or at least she wasn't
there when he appeared in the 40th
Century not of the way that she is here
so again it's Marvel just kind of
Shifting things around and really
retelling the origin of ravana which
really kind of begs the question is King
volume 1 a retelling of of Kings origin
or a reworking of ravana right like if
you had to pick one as the main focus of
the story which one would it be I mean
technically it's both but which one does
it lean more towards I guess is the more
accurate question to ask but when he
shows up here of course immediately
being met by ravana the the whole idea
behind life in this future is that it's
very harsh right it is a very harsh and
just a battle hardened life and more
often than not in Marvel Comics that's
how the future is depicted to us is
given to us in different ways but the
future's shown as a very hard and Bleak
and dark place right Days of Future Past
the era of Apocalypse in the far-flung
future right when apocalypse rules the
world this era of Kang all these
different things right it's a very harsh
and difficult place to be in right new
Canaanites versus the chosen or the
clanicaba or whatever it is is always
that kind of thing right so it's really
interesting to see that Marvel sort of
keeps this maintained but against these
forces what you have here is ravana
rensslayer leading by all standards of
measurement A Primitive race for the
most part that there are weapons and
arms and Armament here but because of
because of the fact that society as it
existed at the time had effectively
collapsed these arms and Armament are
Beyond ravana rensslayer inner people's
ability to understand they can use them
to a degree but they can't use them to
their fullest potential and so what's
really cool is that as the two of them
fight together much like what we saw in
their initial appearances in ancient
Egypt they fall in love just like they
did before that their love is born and
bred in Conflict just like it was before
and the two of them working as a group
Face Off against the the these Barbarian
hordes just like they did before the big
difference here though is that what you
have is this point where once these
forces are defeated again the world's
not saved so to speak it's just this
kind of immediate battle that what you
have is that with these forces
essentially defeated that Nathaniel
tells ravana like you're like like
you're amazing and and and I love you
the thing about this though is that he
always speaks of a time in which they'd
known each other in the past she doesn't
know him she's as far as she's concerned
she's never met him so what he's trying
to do is he's trying to kind of continue
on the life they could have had with a
person who knows nothing of that life
right as far as she's concerned and the
way that she feels he feels like he's
losing her and he's pushing you know
forcing himself on her and she's
rebuking him in that way right I mean
she she's growing to care about him but
he's basically moving too hard too fast
and as a result of that he basically
tells her like we can leave this place
right like like together we can leave we
can leave this life behind and we can go
to a place where we can live a glorious
life and when he gives her that
Revelation she immediately turns against
it now there's a few different reasons
as to why she turns against it and turns
against him the first is because this is
the only life she knows it's the only
life that she's even willing to accept
she can't imagine a life where there is
no such thing as conflict or war or
anything along those lines but the
bigger idea behind this is that because
of the life that she's lived she's grown
to become ridiculously independent and
doesn't see herself as somebody that can
be claimed by any person and the idea of
Nathaniel showing up here using what is
in effect an archaic standard of love
and connection and saying that like
you're my girl we knew each other in the
past right you don't know me now but you
can know me again I'm gonna take you
away from this place it almost puts her
in a feeling of being subservient which
is something that she immediately
regrets and so in doing so that's what
she says like you would you would tell
me that you knew me in the past right
she says all this power that you have
you used to claim me as you claim this
woman that you loved except that she is
not me and I am not yours I belong to
myself and the moment that we've made
this moment we've had here will be our
last you will never see me again and she
leaves and so in essence and that's
what's kind of cool here is that the way
ravana rimslayer is depicted here these
different instances where she appears in
the life of Nathaniel and then he loses
her that's designed to mirror the
appearances of ravana rensslayer in the
life of Kane the Conqueror the
difference is that in those lies it was
usually her being betrayed and her being
killed in front of Kang or something
along those lines but regardless no
matter how the circumstance played out
it was each one of them losing the woman
they loved and in losing the woman they
loved ultimately where Kang saw that as
a weakness Nathaniel sees it as how it
is that he becomes king and so that's
why he says he kind of reiterates the
words that were told to him by King
never love and he says as if it were a
choice and then he just kind of steps
into everything right he accepts his
role and he says fine if the choice was
to be mine between a heart pierced by
her gaze and one hardened against her
then I would choose Conquest like in
effect he's tired of losing her right
he's tired of experiencing all this loss
and all this pain over and over and over
again and so what he says is my Army was
unwashed untrained Savage and cruel but
one fact is true throughout time slaves
will become slavers when given a chance
to hold the Whip and he says ravana was
incorrect my mind was my greatest tool
for the weapons of war left behind by
those magic fools in her stories were
made of the very technology I had
trained to repair in those long and
listless Childhood Days complexity had
worn on me he says I wish for something
simple and so I offered all the simplest
Choice join me or die many chose death
and so what this means is that he goes
forward literally as a conqueror that he
starts to build this suit up for himself
that basically looks like the suit of
Kane the Conqueror that much like Kane
the conquer he starts to conquer the
world and then once he gets bored
conquering Earth he sets his sights out
on the entirety of the Galaxy itself
right and then the universe and over and
over and over again taking his forces
with him he conquers everyone and it's
so cool because he says my 100 Year
Conquest had begun he says what it once
seemed so distant so esoteric so
impossibly vast was now Within Reach I
needed only weight and watched the 40th
Century fall before me but I was not a
man of patience and with my time ship
reforged all of reality awaited my rule
should I have sat surrounded by the
ghosts of lost loves pondering how I
might learn from them or indulge my
glory across the fabric of space-time to
Nathaniel it may have been a quandary to
Kang it was no choice at all and so he
says to ground the kings of the past to
dust Arthur most of all his cries were
not those of a hero but of a child who
thought Destiny would not be swayed
against him the cosmosian monarchs
believe themselves safe in their Quantum
Dimension I showed them the error of
their ways then blessed their endless
cities by reforging them as factories
for my time spanning war machine over
and over and over again is the exact
same way he meets immortus he defeats
immortus he meets the Scrolls he defeat
the Scrolls the Batoon the Shia
literally the entire universe is
conquered by Kank that Nathaniel and
that's what's so crazy here that were
Kang like the the king that initially
appeared saw love as weakness Nathaniel
sees it as strength not in the sense
that it's his love for ravana rensslayer
that makes him the person that he wants
to become But ultimately it was the
losing of Love of ravana rensslayer that
drove him to become the person that he
is and so ultimately he says once all of
this was said and done at the end of the
day I still never found anything I still
couldn't feel anything I had conquered
the entirety of the universe and yet
something was still missing from my life
some thing that I felt like I needed
that I wanted I simply just couldn't
find anymore and so what he does is he
travels back to Earth after hearing that
there is a single Kingdom out there that
remains unconquered by his forces and so
ultimately when he arrives here that he
ends up finding that this is the last
free Kingdom that's ruled by ravana
rensslayer now it's it's been quite some
time since the ravana rim Slayer he
immediately met and in fact he even
comments on that he was like okay it was
her it was ravana rinselayer yet again
right a different face but those same
eyes and so what this seems to hit at is
that ravana winslayer is in a lot of
ways a concept an ideology I mean she is
a person but the big question that has
to be asked here which we'll actually
find out really in the next video
is how it is that ravana rensslayer
keeps reappearing as different people in
the time stream right how is it that in
the days of ancient Egypt she had
appeared albeit not necessarily uh as
the ravana rinselayer that we're
familiar with she shows up in the motto
or really about 100 years ago in the
40th century and then she shows up again
here and each time she seemingly looks
different how does that happen but the
reality here is that when he does appear
to ravana rensslayer the first thing he
wants to do is win her heart right the
first thing he wants is to have his girl
back but the reality here is she sees
him as a conqueror she doesn't see him
as a person she could love she sees him
as a person that she absolutely hates
and so what he really realizes is that
the only way to get ravana rensslayer
the only way to get her love is to show
her who he really is because the reality
here and this is one of the best things
about this story came the Conqueror as
you see him here he's not genuinely that
guy but Nathaniel is not genuinely some
warlord that wants to conquer all of
existence for no other reason the fact
that it feeds his ego what he's what he
wants is to find some measure of meaning
out there what he's doing here by
conquering everything is filling the
hole in his heart that was left by not
having ravana Rim Slayer but who he is
at his core is a genuinely great person
right it's a genuinely good guy and
that's when he realizes I have to
actually show her who I am in order for
her to truly love me and that's what he
starts doing right that's literally what
he starts doing is he starts basically
operating as effectively a hero right
that he calls off the attack on her
kingdom and then he frees her kingdom
and says like you do your thing right
like your kingdom is totally hit like we
are hands off not only that he basically
allies himself as Heroes right the ones
that were essentially time to but he had
he acts as Heroes all the while his
General right boltag is plotting against
him and so there comes a point where in
reality the idea of ravana rinselayer as
she appears here being killed does
happen at the hands of baltag right it
does happen as him who ultimately does
shoot her and so basically taking him
out as the traitor saves the life or
seems to save the life of ravana
rensslayer and so ultimately he wins her
heart but he finally gets ravana Rin
slayer's love and in that moment baltag
shoots her right in the moment when he
basically Reveals His role as a traitor
before Kane can act without a run Slayer
is killed and so that's it's one of the
coolest moments here right he says I
prepare to end baltag as Kang never had
but for a moment I stay my hand for I
have fallen in love and it is not
conquered me it is my Mercy she has
grown to love I win and time lasts
because once she's dead and gone it's
the thing where she says maybe it was
just never meant to be maybe we were
just never meant to be together and Kang
basically almost breaks on on this
personal level right the one chance he
had to finally have ravana rensslayer
the closest he ever got to having the
woman of his dreams and is yanked away
it's pulled away because in reality King
and King can never have ravana and
Slayer right it's the the torment of him
as a person he will never get ravana he
will never be in love with ravana he
will never have the life he wants with
ravana that's never going to happen and
so what he does and this basically goes
into how it is that Ren Slayer appears
across the time stream and he says and
so it was then that I devised a new
Escape my love one the old man could
never have accomplished one that I know
I already will he spent the next 50
years warning you when you initially
died he says in his time right King's
time he spent the next 50 years mourning
you trying to bring you his ravana back
but I have seen your face in the distant
past and I have seen your face only a
hundred years ago and I see you here now
and where he was told never love he says
I have already seen the ripples in the
waters of time but I remained so
ignorant as to the impact that caused
them but I know now what else could it
be I am the impact and I shall shatter
time for you awake ravana awake 1 000
times and be saved by my final conquest
and so the goal of Kane the Conqueror is
to quite literally shoot ravana
rensslayer's Essence into the time
stream and basically use that as a way
to find a reality where he can have
ravana rinselayer back so it's really
cool right again it's as much a
retelling as keeping components of the
original origin of King and Tech I mean
I would surmise all this is being done
because of Kang in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but it's really cool uh in this
video and this what's really cool here
about this conclusion is that this is
what really solidifies King and and I
would say removes him from being just
kind of like this ambiguous conqueror
that exists out there in the Multiverse
somewhere that like does things from
time to time and actually brings these
are more Down to Earth because in
reality that's kind of what Kang needed
that over the years and Marvel Comics
King has just kind of been this guy who
exists in the future sometimes he shows
up he fights The Avengers every once in
a while you get like what is it the
original Avengers forever and the
timekeepers and immortus and all that
kind of stuff in the destiny Force but
you never really got to see a story that
focused so heavily on why Kang is the
way he is and what this one does is it
really changes that so the idea here is
that following what was basically the
death of ravana Ren's Slayer right the
one woman he's ever loved more than any
other that Kang's desire to conquer was
less about just like creating some
massive Empire for himself right in the
last video we talked about how he did
that but it left him feeling empty it
didn't fill that hole that he thought it
would fill because the reality is that
hole was reserved for rivona rensslayer
but without her in the picture he just
wasn't really able to do the kind of
things he wanted to do and that's what
was so cool is because he didn't feel
complete when it comes to this idea of
love and this is one of the things that
I want to specify here right when it
comes to the idea of love I think it's
very easy to take a cynical approach
right love is the only socially
acceptable version of masochism right
like we go out into the world and we
intentionally harm ourselves over and
over and over again in the hopes that it
won't actually hurt this time and we'll
find the person we love more than any
other it's very easy to become cynical
in that way when it comes to the notion
of love and for fair reason right I mean
there are people who've been hurt so
consistently that they just by default
associate love with pain because that's
the only thing love has ever caused them
is pain but the reality here is that
depending on who you talk to some people
will say it's worth it and what Kang is
doing here this is one of the things to
know the establishment of chronopolis
was not built at some place for Kane to
basically rule his Empire from some
distant point in the future across the
entirety of the Multiverse instead it
was to basically find his love and so
when he establishes chronopolis one of
the things to know and the easiest way
to understand this is that it's like
this Empire right this Citadel that he
has that has strings across the
Multiverse he is almost like like Thor
in the bifrost right that like you have
Asgard and you have the bifrost bridge
that allows Thor to access any of the
dimensions that are tied to the bifrost
chronopolis allows Kane to access any of
the universes that he's conquered and
even some of the ones that he hasn't
right it allows him to basically travel
back and forth throughout the entirety
of the time stream and the Multiverse
it's just kind of his base of operations
it was also the base of operations for
immortus as well but the thing about
this is is why it was built was because
of the fact that what he wanted to do
was create a place whereby he could
essentially scatter the entirety of
ravana Rin slayer's atoms across the
time stream now I know it sounds kind of
crazy in doing that but he literally
says I call this place chronopolis he
says this is where we will live ravana
and he says where you'll live I swear it
even if it takes a thousand attempts she
was not you but she had wisdom go my
ravana and be infinitely reborn in the
space between the Stars so the idea of a
client behind King here is to basically
scatter her entire existence across the
Multiverse and she'll be reborn in every
single universe that exists across the
Multiverse at that point is him just
trying to find things now what he says
here is so intriguing he says in those
moments of Mastery for I had become the
master of time I often thought that
epochs and eras were measurements for
lesser men that had not invented the
chronology that could contain Kank I
brought the chronopolis the greatest
monks of the Buddha and the most
enlightened Shia Warrior priest and
through their teachings and on rare
occasions over their corpses I came to
an understanding a master does not allow
his love to die those are the actions of
a boy a master compels that which he
controls to become that which he loves
using every bit of chronopolis's power I
unravel the very fabric of time I found
the threads of fate and made the city
its Loom and from it I wove a machine of
constant replication I injected ravana
Rin slayer's very Soul into time like a
die into the threads of an entire
tapestry where time had taken her from
me I forced time to do the opposite the
birth of an infinite number of ravanas
in infinite timelines giving myself
infinite chances to save her the plan
was genius it was Flawless until it
began and what we end up finding out
here and this is one of the interesting
things dick hang really is it's almost
as though Kang has this Mastery of time
but he's also a slave to it because
every single reality that he goes to no
matter what he does she always dies that
in one reality she dies from the plague
in another reality she actually rejects
him right and it takes him by surprise
but no matter what he does and no matter
how hard he tries he always loses ravana
rensslayer there's nothing he can do to
have her no matter what the circumstance
is there's no way to get her and after
all these countless attempts after all
these efforts what it's done is has
turned him cold and that's one of the
things to know here that's one of the
thing to see is that what we don't
necessarily know the exact origin of the
original King at the beginning of the
story that went back and visited
Nathanael who became this version of
Kang that we're seeing now all we know
is that their Origins seem very very
closely intertwined that the causation
behind what made them who they are is
still the exact same thing that when he
finally finds a version of ravana
rinselayer that he's that he comes to
believe may love him the reality is she
rejects him and it's not due to anything
regarding his character or at least his
physical form and so far that she finds
it unattractive or anything like that
she rejects him because of his character
and what he'd done to her and what she
really States here is she says the great
machine knows time it sees all those who
manipulated plus I could smell you
across the time stream you hideous
Jackal and she says my life you made me
believe you were a good man and then you
stole my life and where King says no I
saved you ravana you saved me and I
loved you I love you so I saved you the
response here is she says my life was
not yours to save my life was my life
right I died presumably when I was
supposed to or by whatever manner or
whatever means but what you've done is
you've taken my life away from me right
you have taken away my ability to
actually live a life that was meant for
me instead every life I've ever lived
across the entirety of this Multiverse
has all been engineered by you every
single life has been designed like
intricately by you not in so far is
exactly how her life unfolded but
basically she was created for a purpose
and the purpose was to satisfy the
desire of King to have someone in his
life imagine if that were the case right
imagine if tomorrow somebody showed up
to you to visit you and said hey the
whole reason you exist is because I
created you and I created you for the
express purpose of being my lover
suddenly your life has no meaning your
life has no value because the life you
lived was never truly your own and
that's what she experiences here that's
what really torments her here and so
where Kang realizes she's kind of a
failure that also really King says okay
fine another failure there's nothing I
can do here he goes to attack her and
basically destroy her and in the process
of this she destroys chronopolis right
she says you're the wound in the time
stream King like you fail to realize
even after all of this you're the
problem and that's one of the things
that that Kane says here right he says
that all that's left to do here is to
cauterize the wound and he says I do not
remember these moments well right
because just his whole manipulation with
time screws with his memory and he says
I think I did not want to remember the
screams and he says and of course time
was collapsing the end of my rescue
operation was much closer than I'd
imagined so the mind as it often does
while exposed to the time stream Place
tricks it erases efficiently redacts and
kindly revises but I can still remember
her smile and the terror that it
inspired and so literally as the final
Act of this ravana rinselayer before
she's destroyed she annihilates the
entirety of the chronopolis and so he
says the ashes of chronopolis are there
if you look for them no matter what your
temporal position a bit of dirt on your
mantle a penny from the distant year a
book that you swore to read the
chronopolis just as its very function in
operation literally exploded throughout
the time stream with its atoms and bits
and pieces just kind of skewed
everywhere and what he says is that in
its destruction Kang unlike you and I
who would just kind of be blown back
maybe a hundred feet or 50 feet or 500
feet or whatever it is King was blown
through the time stream and so he
literally fell through time and so it's
one of those things because as he was
falling he says I arrived 10 minutes
early and then ultimately he arrived to
see his younger self and he says I was
younger than I'd remembered Nathaniel
Richards eyes I remembered once as my
own I had felt so powerful so capable I
looked at Kang with disdain the sneer
was insufferable I swore to erase it
from the boy I gave him the chance I'd
been given by the monster sister who
made me but with the benefit of my
knowledge I would give him the trauma I
would do it right right I would correct
the mistakes of of essentially my father
right I would correct the mistakes of
the king that came to me that visited me
when I was younger and brought me
through the time stream what's so
beautiful about this story is it's the
relation between a father and a son now
it's not exactly a father and a son but
by all standards a measurement You could
argue that it is right king's parents
when he was a child were already dead he
was basically raised without any real
parents at all so when King from the
future came back to visit his younger
self took him under his wing into the
time stream he very much became a father
figure but what he was was a father
figure that was traumatized by his own
experiences his own abuses his own
personal torment and as a result of that
much like a lot of parents out there he
passed that on to his child and so it's
really an answer to the question what
happens when a child is raised by a
parent that never learns the real
lessons of their own experiences and
that they try to to impart on their
children the better parts of themselves
but in their failure to learn their
lessons they ultimately impart on them
the worst parts of themselves that at
the end of the day the story of Kang is
cyclical it's always a circumstance
where Kang always becomes king but
notice this it's not Kang showing up
here and saying I will teach you to
become a conqueror so that you may
enslave all of existence no he says I
remember the wood under my fingers the
betrayer tears that left unbiden into my
eyes did his mouth Taste of bile did I
lay bleeding did he shiver and sweat and
he says did he feel the Noose tightened
around his throat an inescapable moment
a broken heart hate Fury so hot it will
burn the stars and so ultimately that's
what happens right he says what had been
was again the lesson he needed the one
that in my Fury I felt forced to teach a
lesson and so ultimately it's exactly
the same thing doesn't matter what
happened no matter how things unfolded
Kang can never have ravana to run Slayer
he will never have that woman in his
life he is always destined to lose that
which he loved the most and like any
rational human being out there in the
face of losing what they love the most
he felt anger and instead of accepting
the fact that that's just the way things
unfolded for him he basically took that
anger and that rage and passed it on to
his younger self and what he thought was
basically the right lesson to teach
never love and so literally the cycle of
abuse just continues that while the
lessons may have been a little bit
different or how he taught his younger
self may have been a little bit
different at the end of the day the root
cause was the exact same and so that's
how Kang always becomes king that he
says one last chance to save ravana I
had been given one last chance and I
done only what time demanded I was no
master I was a boy it made me hate him
all the more that she knew me even from
the start as I danced with Addie she
knew she knew me for what I am but all I
wanted to be was more than Nathaniel
Richard and so in the end what he was
trying to do was basically make
Nathanael the opposite of him he was
trying to make Nathaniel a person that
wouldn't become him but the lesson that
Nathaniel learned just like the lesson
this version of Nathaniel learned when
he was visited by the king before him
was that that version of Kang was a bad
guy that he would seek to destroy him
all the while failing to realize he
would become him and that's what he says
right he says that like that younger
version of Nathaniel left in the night
stealing the only time armor that he
thought Kang owned and Kang even says
run Nathanael run and become you think
me conquered but it was not Kang who has
died this day for Nathaniel Richards is
not a boy nor a man nor hero nor a
villain he is only a beginning and he
says a king and a tyrant a villain and a
hero we will be all things experience
all things the beginning and ending of
time and hours by immortality's Boon you
will have the power of a God and when
you have lived an Immortals life still
here you will stand never love and he
says how could I when there is no one
left to love across all of time my
ravanas are gone my past affixed it's
Loop completed her grip upon my heart
releases and so the husk stops I have
found my desiccation and he says let
Armageddon be a funeral pyre for there
is but one escape from eternity's Trap
and I stand upon its precipice I need
not even jump I need merely to finally
rest Alexander wept because he could not
conquer himself but I am not Alexander
and literally that world that he's in
right when that meteor strikes he's
there at the very moment and simply
leaves right just leaves on his own
vessel and he says rest in fire
Nathaniel Richards rest knowing you have
bested all you thought to be great in
this world die knowing you stand a
stride Destiny give your face and voice
to he who created and who turn created
you and above all things though all on
time and space make Inspire to defeat
you never ever love that's the irony of
this that's the irony and the beauty of
this whole story that when Kang when
when this version of Kang was visited by
the king before him that that King said
never love all it's going to do is bring
you pain and suffering and sadness and
the response of Nathanael was that's
because you didn't know love all you
knew was conquering loves the greatest
feeling in existence is the greatest
thing of all and that at the end of the
day this that that younger Nathaniel
went on his quest to find a way to
defeat that King to destroy that King to
show that version of King that love
truly is powerful but when he encounters
it what that younger Nathaniel failed to
realize is the power of love is so
extreme that it can break a person on
the most fundamental level and I'm not
talking about those those guys out there
who really liked the girl in their
science class and they don't like them
back and so love is bad no no I'm
talking about the people who gave their
life to someone right I'm talking about
those men and women out there right who
lived a life with somebody else who
spent years together right brushing
their teeth next to each other for 30
years and truly understand the meaning
of sacrifice right and that significant
other just changed their mind one day
and left or they were hit by a car and
they died whatever the case is that that
person became that person's other half
right like they had spent so much time
together that they were intertwined in a
way that can scarcely be defined and
when that person either left or or was
taken from them that that person had
become half their heart and half their
mind and half their soul and how do you
live without that right and so to truly
understand what it means to love and
then to have that taken away and to not
only have it taken away to know you can
never get it back it can break a person
on the most basic and fundamental level
and that's what younger Nathaniel never
accounted for that's what he never
considered is what that what what it
really meant to love and then what it
meant to never be able to have that love
that's what broke him and so that's the
the interesting lesson here is at the
end of the day the Conqueror despite all
of his wanted power and despite all the
things he says and all the things he
does and the grand campaigns and all
that kind of stuff Kang is nothing more
than a guy who exists out there in time
and has experienced a broken heart an
infinite number of times but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
I absolutely love this story probably
the single greatest story that's ever
been told about Kang and I will catch
you all later
peace